Please welcome back to our program,
our dear friend, Neil DeGrasse Tyson.
(audience applauds and cheers)
And of course, our environmental and lifestyle expert,
Danny Seo, for another round of Earth Day Trivia Showdown.
(audience applauds)
(lively percussive music)
All right, you know the rules,
each correct answer is worth one point.
Wait until I've read the questions
and multiple choice options before you hit your buzzer.
And if you answer correctly, you earn a point.
The contestant with the most points, duh, wins
the coveted Earth Day trophy.
(triumphant fanfare music)
Ooh.
(audience applauds)
Okay.
Number one, in the average home,
which of the following uses the most water?
A, flushing the toilet.
B, taking a 10 minute shower,
or C, washing one load of laundry.
(bell pings)
Yeah, I think it's laundry.
I think laundry does that.
Is that your final answer?
That's my final answer.
(klaxon buzzes)
(Neil groans)
(audience laughs)
Danny, do you have a different theory?
Well, now he gets to answer one out of two.
That's true.
You're right.
Okay, that's fine, that's fine.
That's how this works.
I know how math works.
I'm one outta three.
I made it easier for him.
Okay.
(audience applause ripples)
Fine.
Go.
I'll take your charity.
I'm going with shower.
That was correct.
(bell dings)
(audience applauds)
All right, num-
Wait, wait.
And even with the water restricted
shower nozzles they have today?
I'm just saying.
Yeah, come on.
That water is a trickle now.
Yeah, don't be a sore loser.
I'm a... (laughs)
(audience laughs)
All right, number two.
What is the most reused material in the world?
A, steel,
B, plastic,
C, paper.
(bell pings)
I'm gonna go with steel.
The same way I'm gonna steal the second trophy.
(bell dings)
Oh!
(audience applauds)
Fun fact.
In North America, we recycle around 80 million tons
of steel each year.
From cars and skyscrapers,
to soup cans and sardine tins,
steel is used to make many of the objects
that we interact with every day.
Cool.
Okay, number three.
A single mature tree produces enough air supply
for how many people a year?
A, 10,
B, four,
C, one.
(bell pings)
Neil?
Yeah. I'm going with 10.
(klaxon buzzes)
(audience laughs)
It is B.
Oh.
Four. Oh.
I don't? Oh.
(all laugh)
(audience laughs)
Well I felt bad for giving you that,
so I'm just gonna take the lead.
Okay.
It's answer B, it's four.
On average, a 50 year old tree
will produce 6,000 pounds of breathable oxygen
in its lifetime.
Number four, which of these household items
cannot be recycled?
A, plastic shower curtains,
B, fluorescent light bulbs,
or C, home keys.
(bell pings)
Shower curtain.
(bell dings)
The ding means what (stutters) he's right.
He gets the point.
Man.
(audience applauds)
The takeaway here is that some plastic shower curtains
are made of PVC, also known as Plastic Number Three,
which has toxic chemicals.
Drew, I haven't gotten one right yet.
Neil, there is a lot you do know.
You gotta put one in there for me.
All right.
Neil, I think there's
a lot more in your mind than shower curtains.
Okay. (laughs)
Just so you, in fairness.
But still. Okay.
I'ma try hard and really focus.
Meteor, like meteor showers.
All right.
Ooh, I like that.
Meteor showers, shower curtains.
I take meteor showers.
Yes, exactly.
There you go, how d'you like that, okay.
All right, number five,
which of the following takes the longest time to break down
or disintegrate?
A, disposable diaper,
B, aluminum can,
or C, a plastic straw.
(bell pings)
Plastic straw.
(klaxon buzzes)
(audience laughs)
This is weird that we spoke of Kim Kardashian
and skins and diapers,
because the answer is A, it's a disposable diaper.
It takes 500 years for disposable diapers to degrade,
creating methane and other toxic gases in the process.
Plastic straws take 200 years,
and aluminum cans take 250 years.
Boo to babies.
(Neil laughs)
(audience laughs)
Boo!
(Neil applauds)
Cancel babies!
(all laugh)
Okay, number six,
how much of the world's water is available for human use?
A, 23%,
B, 54%,
or C, 1%.
(bell pings)
That's 1%.
(bell dings)
True, yeah.
Yes.
Neil!
Yeah!
(audience applauds)
Only about 3% of Earth's water is fresh water.
And of that, only 1% can be used as drinking water,
the rest, or I say potable,
the rest is locked up in glaciers, ice caps,
or buried deep in the ground
and most of our drinking water
comes from rivers and streams.
This was if a tiebreaker was needed.
(Neil laughs)
(audience laughs)
But I think-
You don't have to
rub it in like that.
I know, I'm sorry.
This is cool.
I'm just fun fact.
What year was the first Earth Day year?
(bell pings)
What?
It happened while we were walking on the moon, in 1970.
(bell dings)
(audience applauds)
I still lose though.
Thanks.
Just saying.
(audience laughs)
That is true.
Congrats to Danny Seo.
A second trophy.
(audience applauds and cheers)
(Neil and Drew laugh)
(bright theme music)